JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been learning
about two-dimensional flux
and the normal form of
Green's theorem-- so normal
here meaning perpendicular--
so I want to give you
a problem about that.
So what I'd like you
to do is to verify
Green's theorem in normal form
for this particular field,
the field F equals x i hat
plus y j hat and the curve C
that consists of the upper
half of the unit circle
and the x-axis
interval minus 1 to 1.
So first of all, let me
say what I mean by this C.
So C, it's the usual unit
circle, circle of radius 1
centered at the origin,
so just its top half,
And the x-axis
interval minus 1 to 1,
I mean the line segment that
connects the points (-1, 0)
and (1, 0), so the diameter
of that semicircle.
So that's the curve
C and the field F.
What I mean by verify
Green's theorem
is I'd like you to compute
both the double integral that
appears in Green's theorem and
the line integral that appears
in Green's theorem
and check that they're
really equal to each other.
So that'll confirm
Green's theorem
in this particular
instance and hopefully
help give us a feel for
how it works a little bit.
So why don't you pause
the video, have a go,
compute both of those
integrals, come back
and we can work
them out together.
Hopefully you had
some luck with this.
Let's have a go at it.
So what Green's
theorem tells you
is that the flux across
a curve, which we usually
compute as a line
integral, is also
equal to an integral of the
divergence over the region
bounded by that curve.
So here the curve has to be
a closed curve so that it
bounds a region of the plane.
So in particular, let's
draw the picture here
so we know what
we're talking about.
So the curve C, so we've got
the segment from minus 1 to 1
along the x-axis, and
then we have the top half
of the unit circle.
That's the curve C. And I
didn't specify an orientation
but in any context
like this, when
you don't specify an
orientation, what you
mean is positively oriented.
So it's a positively
oriented curve.
So that's our curve C.
And so the region that
it bounds is this half
of the circle, the semicircle.
I keep saying half
of the semicircle.
Sorry about that.
This upper half of the
circle, of the disc, in fact.
That region of the plane.
OK, so what Green's
theorem tells
us is that when we compute
the surface integral-- sorry,
the double integral--
of the divergence of F
over this region, that
should be the same as what
we do if we compute F
dot n around the boundary
of the curve.
And now we're going to check it.
So let's do the
double integral first.
The double integral
in this case,
so it's the double
integral over--
let me call that region R-- so
it's the double integral over R
of the divergence of F dA.
So what is the divergence of F?
Well, here's F. It's
x i hat plus y j hat.
So its divergence
is the partial of x
with respect to x, plus the
partial of y with respect to y.
So that's 1 plus 1.
So the divergence of F
is just 2, in this case.
So it's equal to
the double integral
over the semicircle of 2 dA.
And of course when you integrate
a constant over a region, what
you get is just that constant
times the area of the region.
So dA here is the area
of the semicircle,
it's half of a
circle of radius 1.
So circle of radius
1 has area pi.
So this is 2 times 1/2 pi.
So this is pi.
OK.
So that's the double
integral that we
get from Green's
theorem in normal form.
And what Green's theorem
says is that this
is equal to a particular
line integral.
So what is the line integral?
Well, it's the integral
around C of F dot n.
So let's write down what it
is, the line integral part now.
So it's an integral.
It's a closed curve.
So it's integral
around C of F dot n ds.
So that is the line integral
that we're looking to compute.
So how do we compute this?
Well, usually we compute it
by using the coordinates of F.
So this is equal to, and we know
that this is always equal to,
the integral around
C of-- and let
me make sure I'm getting this
right before I screw anything
up.
Yes.
OK, I am.
Good.
M*dy minus N*dx, where M and
N are the coordinates of F--
or the components of F. M and
N are the components of F.
So M is the first component
and N is the second component.
So in our case, F has
this fairly simple form.
So in our case, this is
equal to the integral
around C of-- so M, the
first component of F is x.
So this is x*dy minus-- the
second component is y*dx.
So this is the line integral
we're interested in computing.
But, of course,
this curve is not
easy to parameterize
as a single go.
So we want to split
it into two pieces.
So let's look.
So the first piece we
want to split it into
is that line segment.
So let's call that maybe--
well, I'm not even going
to bother giving them names.
We want to split it into
the integral over the line
segment plus the integral
over the semicircle.
The boundary of that--
yes, the semicircle.
So this is equal to-- so it's
the integral over the line
segment.
So let's see.
So that integral-- well,
OK, I will give them names.
I will give them names.
I take it back.
We'll call the line
segment C_1 and we'll
call the semicircle C_2.
So it's equal to the
integral over C_1--
OK, well, what is the
integral over C_1?
What are x and dy and
y and dx in this case?
So in this case, well, x
is what we're integrating.
But dy, we're on this line
segment, y isn't changing.
y is constant.
So dy is just 0.
So it's 0 minus-- OK, and now on
this line segment y is 0 also.
So it's 0*dx.
So the first integral,
the integral over C_1,
is the integral of 0.
Plus-- we have to
integrate over C_2 of-- OK,
so x*dy minus y*dx.
All right.
So this one's just going
to be 0, that's easy.
So now we just have to
work with this second one.
OK, so for the second
one, we're integrating
over the semicircle, so we
want to parameterize it.
And we're going to use our
usual parameterization.
x equals cosine t,
y equals sine t.
And in this case, we just
want to do this semicircle.
So we just want to go from
(1, 0) all the way around to
(-1, 0).
So that is from
going from 0 to pi.
So this is equal to-- so this
first integral is just 0.
It's the integral
of 0 and that's 0.
So it's the integral-- OK, so
t is going to go from 0 to pi.
So now x*dy So x is cosine t.
y is sine t.
So dy is sine t dt.
Sorry, it's cosine t dt.
y is sine t.
dy is cosine t dt.
So it's cosine t times cosine
t dt, minus-- all right,
now y is sine t again.
And x is cosine t.
So dx is minus sine t dt.
So this is times
minus sine t dt.
OK, well what happens here?
So this becomes cosine squared
t dt minus minus sine squared t.
Minus minus is plus.
So it's cosine squared t
dt plus sine squared t dt.
But, of course, cosine squared
plus sine squared is just 1.
So we can write this even more
simply as the integral from 0
to pi of 1 dt or just dt, and
the integral dt is just t.
So this is t between
0 and pi, which is pi.
Whew!
OK.
Pi.
Good.
And what did we get before?
We also got pi.
Great.
So we have successfully
verified Green's theorem
in normal form in this
particular instance.
So let's just recap
again what we did.
We had this field
F and this curve
C. This closed curve C
that bounded some region.
And so what we've done is we
computed the double integral
over the region of div F dA.
So that's what we did first.
Double integral over the
region bounded by the curve.
And then second, we
computed the line
integral, around the
boundary, of F dot n ds.
So that was what--
this is always
a useful form in which
to write this F dot n dA.
OK, and then we substituted
and computed it.
And Green's theorem tells
us that the two integrals
have to be equal to each other.
And indeed, for this particular
F and this particular C,
we verified that in this
case they both give us pi.
And, of course, Green's
theorem tells us
that that would have been
true, that they would have come
out the same, regardless
of what the choice of F
and the choice of C
that we made were.
So I'll stop there.